écoute casimir cesse de faire l'idiot je
ne fais pas l'idiot
je fais ce qui me plaît enfin quasiment
tout le monde t'attend pour partir non
non et non je n'irai pas qu'est ce que
je lis va être très déçu oui bien elle
avait qu'à choisir de rester avec moi
bah c'est dommage pour toi casimir parce
qu'elle avait préparée spécialement un
énorme gloubiboulga je n'aime plus le
gloubiboulga écoute les émirs montre-toi
raisonnable enfin pour une fois que nous
avions la chance de pouvoir tous
ensemble aller à la plage faire un pique
nique
il a fallu que tu as eu l'idée saugrenue
de nous emmener sous les hangars de
monsieur prochaine pour jouer à la
marelle mais j'avais dessiné une
magnifique jeu de mares géant ne reste
plus qu'à tenir les enfants n'auraient
pas pu sauter les cases et bien ils
n'avaient qu'à me regarder jouer avec
monsieur du schnabel facteurs mouche
occasion monsieur duchesneau quels
facteurs nous non plus large mais il a
soufflé ce de jouer à la marelle over
alors c'est toujours pareil chaque fois
que j'ai envie de faire quelque chose
tout le monde est contre moi
qasimi tout le monde avait envie d'aller
faire ce pique nique sur la plage tout
le monde sauf toi mais il est tout à
fait normal que ce soit le plus grand
nombre qui décide
casimir juste très bien que dans l'île
aux enfants c'est toujours ainsi que
nous agissons nous aujourd'hui ce n'est
pas comme d'habitude
bon alors maintenant casimir cette fois
ça suffit du cesse de bouder et du lien
avec nos alliés nous non je ne veux pas
y aller je préfère rester tout seul
vraiment absent l'humain et bakassi mire
cette phrase moi je n'assiste plus et tu
sais nous le regretterons beaucoup enfin
du jeu on peut très bien s'amuser quand
on est tout seul il suffit de savoir
s'organiser
veux tu que je te prête ma boîte de
couleurs je n'ai besoin de rien ni de
personne
tout ce que je demande c'est la solitude
tu vas l'avoir casimir je te laisse en
noir enfin bonne journée quand même ça
envoie renvoi quel caractère
mais c'est quand même incroyable si
c'est toujours pareil alors il faut
toujours que je fasse que les autres on
a envie de faire et personne ne veut
jamais faire ce que j'ai envie moi oh
non mais c'est vrai quoi
je suis quand même à casimir us était ma
famille habite cette île depuis 5
millions d'années je suis le descendant
du roi casimir us premier casey mears
deuxième kazimierz troisième casimir us
4e et cetera
non mais si c'est par monsieur du snop
qui peut en dire autant
[Musique]
je suis très bien moi tout seul ici je
n'ai besoin de personne
je suis beaucoup mieux dans le jardin
que sur la plage à manger à un gloubi
boulga plein sable au milieu des enfants
qui font trop de bruit à écouter les
conseils de françois puis sans parler
des les réflexions désagréables de
monsieur du snob les des plaisanteries
stupide du facteur ouais
et puis le locle le rire à leur reer
exaspérant de julie oh je me passe très
bien tout ça ici tout est calme on est
bien ça ça me donne envie de chanter
attention je chante
[Musique]
avec une chanson un peu d'imagination
vous emmène dans notre it is by du
bonheur tranquille
ce qu'on peut rencontrer ne soyez pas
terrorisé
je suis le bon sens qui fait rire
ap el ghazi
une manne machine est une idée
fantastique je mange
l'oubli pour le gag mais je n'en ai pas
marre j'ai vu la ville de caen cannes
ie6 mais marca
c'est mon droit
[Musique]
personne ne m'a applaudi
or c'est vrai j'avais oublié que les
enfants étaient partis sur la plage avec
julie
de toute façon sexy pour moi que je
chante alors j'ai une très bonne idée
je vais faire une farce arts à monsieur
du snob et on va bien rigoler vous allez
voir ah ben non on ne va pas rigoler
parce que moss ou du snob lui aussi est
partie sur la plage ça ne fait rien bon
qu'est ce que je pourrais bien faire
manger ni dg je vais danser
voilà je vais danser je prends ma canne
allons-y
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
jolie julie je t'assure julie tu devrais
être là julie or c'est vrai quand je
suis bec
j'avais oublié quand julie aussi était
parti sur la plage bon il faut que je
trouve autre chose à faire quand vais-je
pouvoir faire mais ça va bientôt être
lors de la de la tournée du facteur
oui il va m'apporter plein de lettres
j'adore lire des lettres oui maintenant
il va pas venir aujourd'hui parce que
lui aussi est allé au pique nique
c'est terrible mais je crois que je
commence à m'ennuyer un petit peu tout
seul c'est triste d'être complètement
seul au milieu du jardin
alors que tous vos amis sont sur la
plage en train de faire un pique nique
un pique nique
rien que d'y penser ça me donne faim
j'ai faim oui j'ai enfin romain non je
ne peux pas manger le kiosque de julie
est fermé ils doivent quand même bien
s'amuser tous ensemble sur la plage en
forme françois doit faire faire des jeux
aux enfants
il ya le facteur qui doit raconter des
histoires drôles
il ya le rire charme julie puis il ya un
monsieur duchesneau à part qu' on peut
faire des farces
ouais ils ont plein de bonnes choses à
manger en plus oui et julie m'a préparé
spécialement un énorme gloubiboulga et
julie prépare très bien le gloubiboulga
elle s'est juste dose et les bonnes
proportions de confiture de fraises de
chocolat râpé de banane écrasée de
moutarde et de saucisses de toulouse il
y à là bas sur la plage un énorme que le
8 bulgares dans un panier avec tous mes
amis autour
et moi je suis là tout seul enfin c'est
quand même pas juste c'est pas juste et
à tanguer mois attend dé moi